The 2014 Nobel prize for chemistry is a bit
unusual this year. If you're a regular viewer of our videos,
you're probably used to the fact that the chemistry Nobel prize can sometimes be
a bit more biological and chemical,
but this Nobel prize is really using almost
physics to study biology, but with a chemical twist to it,
the idea of the prize is it's gone to three scientists who have
devised a way of looking inside biological sales
with microscopy very much better with much greater detail
than has been possible before. And not only looking inside cells,
but looking inside living cells. So you can actually see them working.
Although it's a bit of physics, it's not too complicated.
So let me explain the problem.
The problem is that light is a wave.
If you're trying to look at very small objects, there is a limit.
If you just have a microscope with lenses to the size of the
object, you can see because as the object gets smaller,
comparable or smaller than the wavelength of light,
it just becomes fuzzier and fuzzier. And eventually you can't see it at all.
And the usual way to approach this is that you use instead of light,
you use electron beams where the wavelength is very, very short.
So the object is still bigger than the wavelength of the electrons.
The trouble is that the electrons,
when they have a short wavelength have enormously high energy.
And so if you look at the biological cell,
even if it wasn't dead beforehand,
as soon as you stopped shining electrons on it, it dies.
So you have no hope looking at living things,
and you can't start shining electron beams into the brains
of living organisms.
Let alone humans they're just dies right away.
These prizes, which have been awarded to one scientist in Germany,
Stephan hel two scientists in America, Eric bet,
SIG and William Myrna and Betsy can learn a used
one approach based on fluorescent proteins.
You will remember that a Nobel prize.
I think it was in 2008 was awarded for green
fluorescent proteins. And this is taking it if you like one step further.
And the other, um, technique was developed by, um,
Stephen Hill and involves lasers.
The idea is that you have a cell with something inside it
that you would like to image. And the thing you want to image is smaller,
the wavelength of light.
So if you can see any detail lens side the sale,
it will just be one blur on top of another the idea and not all the scales of
this demonstration, right?
Because I wasn't expecting this Nobel prize and I've just got some
objects lying around my office,
but you take one laser which produces a spot that is determined
by the wavelength of light. If in the cell,
there is something that fluoresces that is when you shine a light,
it gives out a different wavelength of light.
So you shine on green and it gives that red light.
Then the blob of red light that comes out will be the
same size as the spots of green light that you're signed on it,
but it will be much more intense in the center of the spot. Then at the edges,
what Stephan hel discovered,
at least I believe this is what he discovered is that if you use two lasers at
once,
that's a red one and a green one and got the spots to coincide,
which I can't easily do that the red spot
would suppress. Most of the
fluorescence caused by the green one so that the fluorescence became much
sharper, so small,
that it could then be used to scan across the cell and see the
image at much better resolution.
I think what's happens is that the second laser,
and I don't know what the wavelengths are.
I just haven't here to use green and red is that the second laser
stops fluorescence from the part of the first beam where the light is not so
intense, but where in the middle, the first beam is really intense.
Then the second laser can't stop it. The other two,
they were working not together,
but one of the work miRNAs work stimulated breadstick,
and then back again so that they were working like a arguing
couple almost. So that one had an idea and then the other,
but there's involved the fluorescence of just individual
molecules.
And apparently the key breakthrough came with the fact that with the
green fluorescent protein, this is a protein which when you shine it with light,
it fluoresces, it only fluoresces a certain number of times.
So if you hit it with light the first time,
it then starts fluorescing and it gives that light.
And you can repeat this perhaps 10 times and then it stops.
Then you have to shine a different colored light and you can switch it on again.
And then by quite a complicated process,
which I don't entirely understand is by using
different colored fluorescent proteins, yellow, red,
green, and hitting it with a laser,
making it fluoresce,
then letting it go quiet because it's switched off and then
switching it on again,
you can build up a picture of the inside of the cell,
a very great resolution.
I think even without understanding all
the details of how they did it,
the fact that now one can look inside living
cells and see things going on that nobody's ever been able to see
before.
Since the invention of the microscope is obviously a wonderful
discovery and something which
nobody I think would argue isn't worthy of a Nobel prize.
It may be that this particular year
with the blue led going to physics and this
microscopy going to chemistry that if had been choosing,
I might've put them the other way round because there's a lot of chemistry in
the led and a lot of physics in the microscopy,
but who are we to argue with the Swedish Academy?
They understand Nobel prizes better than anybody else.